neurons are specialized cells that
transmit information
within the nervous system they are
arranged into complex networks of
circuits that enable our thoughts
sensations and actions
neurons transmit information through two
different molecular processes in the
first of these processes a signal is
passed from cell to cell via chemical
messengers called neurotransmitters
this occurs at the synapse the
convergence point of two neurons
one neuron releases neurotransmitters
from storage vesicles into the synaptic
cleft a small gap separating the two
neurons
[Music]
there are many types of
neurotransmitters that carry different
types of signals
for example the neurotransmitter
glutamate is an agent in pain signaling
among many other pathways as shown here
glutamate binds to its receptor causing
the receptor to open its ion channel and
allow ions to enter the neuron
this ionic influx initiates the second
signaling process that neurons employ
the action potential
to understand how these ions initiate
the action potential we need to examine
the neuronal membrane when the neuron is
at rest
in the resting state various types of
ions surround the membrane
outside the neuron the dominant ion type
is sodium while inside the dominant ion
type is potassium both are positively
charged
this unbalanced ionic distribution forms
concentration gradients across the
membrane
neurons establish and maintain these
gradients largely by the sodium
potassium pump a membrane protein that
pumps three sodium ions out of the
neuron for every two potassium ions that
it pumps in
but there is one other kind of gradient
here a gradient of charge the positive
charges on the outside are balanced to
some degree by the chloride ions on the
inside the positive charges are balanced
to a better degree by the net negative
charges of cellular proteins
this creates a positive charge on the
outside of the neuron relative to the
inside
we call this difference in charge across
the membrane a voltage
in neurons voltage-gated ion channels
act as gatekeepers for ion traffic
across the membrane
thanks to their voltage sensing domains
these channels open and close in
response to changes in membrane voltage
remember that influx of ions we saw
earlier it causes a change in the
voltage
voltage-gated sodium channels sense this
change and open allowing sodium ions
into the neuron
these sodium ions are flowing down
gradients of both concentration and
charge
their influx triggers more sodium
channels to open creating a positive
feedback loop as neighboring sodium
channels activate one another
this process of continuous amplification
is called an action potential
to prepare for the next action potential
the neuron must terminate the signal
this occurs in four steps
at a critical point the sodium channels
close and become temporarily inactivated
blocking further sodium ion entry
meanwhile the voltage-gated potassium
channels offset the change in voltage by
opening and allowing potassium ions to
exit the neuron
concurrently the sodium potassium pump
restores the original ionic gradients
pumping sodium out and potassium in in a
three to two ratio
finally after a short refractory period
the sodium channels reopen their
inactivation gates and become ready for
the next action potential
once the action potential reaches the
end of the axon it stimulates
neurotransmitter release propagating the
signal onto the next neuron
neurotransmitter release depends on the
presence of calcium ions which are
abundant outside the neuron but sparse
inside
the action potential triggers
voltage-gated calcium channels to open
allowing an influx of calcium ions
these calcium ions then activate special
proteins that mediate the fusing of
vesicles with the membrane
the vesicles release their
neurotransmitters into the synaptic
cleft which diffuse across and start the
signaling cycle anew
together neurotransmitters gradients ion
channels and ion pumps work in harmony
to create the neuronal signaling
symphony
so
[Music]
you